we're told that an electronic store
gives customers the option of purchasing
a protection plan when customers buy a
new television that's actually quite
common
the customer pays 80 for the plan and if
their television is damaged or stops
working the store will replace it for no
additional charge the store knows that
two percent of customers who buy this
plan end up needing a replacement that
cost the store twelve hundred dollars
each
here is a table that summarizes the
possible outcomes from the stores
perspective
let x represent the store's net gain
from one of these plans
calculate the expected net gain so pause
this video see if you can have a go at
that before we work through this
together
so we have the two scenarios here the
first scenario is that the store does
need to replace the tv because something
happens and so it's going to cost twelve
hundred dollars to the store but
remember they got eighty dollars for the
protection plan so you have a net gain
of negative one thousand one hundred and
twenty dollars from the store's
perspective there's the other scenario
which is more favorable for the store
which is the customer does not need a
replacement tv so that has no cost and
so their net gain is just the eighty
dollars for the plan so to figure out
the expected net gain we just have to
figure out the probabilities of each of
these and take the weighted average of
them so what's the probability that they
will have to replace the tv well we know
two percent of customers who buy this
plan end up needing a replacement so we
could say this is 2 over 100 or maybe
i'll write it to 0.02 this is the
probability
of x
and then the probability of not needing
a replacement
0.98
and so our expected net gain is going to
be equal to
the probability of needing a replacement
times the net gain of a replacement so
it's going to be times negative
one thousand one hundred and twenty
dollars and then we're going to have
plus the probability of not needing a
replacement which is
0.98 times the net gain there so that is
80
so we have
zero two times one thousand one hundred
twenty
negative is equal to that and to that
we're going to add i'll open parentheses
point nine eight
times
eighty
closed parenthesis is going to be equal
to
56
so this is equal to 56 and now you
understand why the stores like to sell
these replacement plans